just a couple of Dartmouth kids who made
good and in love football and love
putting stuff in front of us like TV
shows and films we can't get enough of
the people who are behind the lego movie
and spider-man into the spider verse and
last man on earth and the Jump Street
movies I've got Phil Lord and Chris
Miller here on the Rich Eisen show good
to see you guys to see you you got it
Congrats on blessed the hearts being
picked up for a second season so much we
got the call this morning you did really
yeah exactly yeah well I told him I told
him to do it around 9:00 guys this is a
really well produced show you know what
I mean Phil yeah it feels that we were
flat out buttoned up although my fantasy
team just is blowing right now are gone
I mean Chris Brockman over there what
happened hold on a second do you guys
play poker 2 or you don't click yeah
okay so it's kind of talking about
fantasies like talk about bad beats in
poker we've all been there it's tough
for people to kind of get into you know
somebody else's fantasy problems but
it's mine so I again we're wondering if
because it's it's so it's going so
poorly right now now you guys are in a
fantasy league together correct yeah
Team Matthew berry celeb League uh-huh
we are about to lose two miles teller
this week two miles teller yeah why do
you have somebody much better team than
us we have doesn't Draft injured players
yes okay so we're in the same boat yeah
now you Chris Miller
yes we're all over dislike us you're a
Seahawks fan correct that's correct
all right and you Phil Lord as a dolphin
fan you cannot go down that that fantasy
road by any stretch of the imagination
okay no so that's not even part of your
problem one dolphin and the very last
round just so we would have a dolphin
who was that it was Albert Wilson not a
great choice for us but you know he's
gone now he's histories um he's on the
waiver wire of life right now what is it
what is your fantasy team name what did
you guys name it to see Emmy doll Hawks
okay
it's logical I don't know if that would
if that will net you the golden globe
[Music]
wondering if our issue is our fantasy
team name right what do we got well I
don't know can we can we put up so they
could see at least the photograph based
on Andy Reid at this year's owners
meeting okay the any annual NFL owners
meeting where all the coaches get to
take a photograph together
he sat right in the middle of it and put
his left and right legs wherever the
hell he damn pleased so we call him the
man spread centerpiece named our team
man spread centerpiece and that's our
avatar right there which is annually so
speaking of which we thought it was the
right thing to do but we went Davante
Adams first yes then we went taht was a
snake draft we want my god then Damian
Williams we thought he's gonna be that
guy since before LeSean McCoy came to
the Kansas City and that whole thing up
yeah and then we went Patrick mahomes
and we saw what the hell happened last
night so now we're wondering this is it
the team name do easily change the team
name yeah it's the man spread curse it
is the man sprit is the man spread now I
would have said would you suggest a team
name for me but I got a idea man in this
town
my generation came up with see ami go
home so max mix and match their pals the
team name is my ball Zach Ertz
which is pretty good strong strong my
ball Zach Ertz is a great teammate guys
can say it fast to yourself and make
sense you know and that's that smiles
tell her the answer yeah I know so I
what other ones do we have that we've
come in a recently Chris Brockman that
we could ask me maybe okay you do give
out that you I Beckham I bet this is
something you would charge for normal
and say hey can we get Phil Lord and
Chris Miller on a rewrite you don't
punch up unless it is at least six
figures an hour and I got Sean Hockley
Flag parade we had the first take
Molotov cocktail yeah take Molotov
cocktail came from like you know when
Magic Johnson shows up and just speaks
like he's got sodium pentathol running
through he's hooked up to some sort of
truth serum and he goes on first take
and he just it's like a Molotov cocktail
into the Lakers furnace yeah that's what
I'm saying
first take Molotov cocktail I got the
sender's out take four send his out take
one shade shy of Gruden shot I don't
know where we come up with that idea we
just come up with ones in the knee as
you could see his filing system is just
fantastic it's just like a notepad that
he just scribbles them on the right low
bill it's just like post-it notes on a
desk so which is that your process yeah
all right one which would you choose
Phil Lord if you had to choose one right
man spread centerpiece jerry jones
votive candle would say jerry jones
votive candle that's nice which
apparently
out of DeMarcus Ware came on the show
and I asked him as dak Prescott and Zeke
were going back and forth associations
like what's it like to negotiate with
Jerry Jones cuz he had to do that when
he was with the Cowboys and he said that
Jerry once he and the agent would kind
of get close to the same page would
close the deal by bringing the player
into his office dimming the lights no
yes he would be dressed in a suit right
behind a desk and light candles in the
room and have like a heart-to-heart like
how much do you want to be a Dallas
Cowboy counsel this is very strange so
I'm the one who came up with it had to
be a motive yeah DeMarcus if it was
scented he didn't recall I mean I want
centavo Jones Jones personal odor is
Jerry Jones personal another great one
feel like if you have to use a segment
to explain it yes it's no good well it's
like a one-percenter where we rank the
term of art well I mean the centerpiece
does need to have a background story it
makes you curious these guys are again
named clip the name you can sit these
guys consider and say you know but come
up with a name it doesn't need to
explain itself like the lego movie 21
Jump Street
we just I pick it up I understand what
you're doing and then the clever sequel
title 22 jumps yes right look we can't
all water-ski behind you a disguise to
talk about some of your stuff because it
is amazing spider-man into the spider
verse by the great title by the way it's
got a : good lord is it about spider-man
I don't know I can't figure it really
says spider two times in the title now
this this put a statuette if you will
and you're in your mantelpiece this this
was an Oscar winner for Best Animated
Feature and the question is is how did
you come to look like this I mean walk
me through the process of how this looks
the way it is and came to be the way it
was audacious enough to in the pitch for
the movie say it's going to look like
nothing has ever looked before and which
is a really easy thing to say and an
impossible thing to execute a year
before the movie was finished nobody
knew what it looked like it was just an
idea of how a movie could look we wanted
to feel like it was a comic book that
came to life which turned out to be a
real technical challenge to make it
happen but we were sort of like why
can't it look like the art that is
inspired by
you know not just inspire buddy but
actually like it and for like six months
we could only make it look good if the
scene was very dark mm-hmm we couldn't
make anything look good in the daytime
in the daytime yeah but they're very
smart people over there at at Sony image
works and they and we work together for
a long time and they made it look
amazing
and then the idea of how there was just
an alternate world and how in one
alternate world Peter Parker was just a
lonesome loser and did that come from
your brains as well we would never come
up with like a so much love just comes
down and you put it all together
we're just vessels are you guys gonna do
it again is there a plan to do another
one of these that's the hope I don't
think you're being coy now did I just
yeah because take a genius to think that
it could happen okay or that we were
working on on something like right now
okay in the back of our you can confirm
or deny neither except we confirm end
deny you confirm end deny the way great
intentionally coy yeah exactly that is
another one of those help okay
what about another lego movie is that
coming anytime so a lot of like are you
done with Lego movies I wouldn't say
necessarily done but we might take a
little break movie for a little kids oh
yeah all day by the way Chris that's
newborn dad humor oh Diplo's the larger
Legos I thought you meant the digit
world famous like you co-star that's
right how goes my cameo on bless the
heart there's still time so where did
this idea come from this comes from
Emily Spivey was one of the big rock
stars of the writers room of last man on
earth and she was an SNL writer for many
years and she's a superstar and she came
to us and was like I want to do a show
about my hometown of North Carolina and
all the interesting characters that live
there
and we were super excited to help her
out and she's like she made it a really
hard thing to pick up she's like I want
my really close friends Kristen Wiig and
Maya Rudolph to be in it and then I
compared Holtz Kumail Nanjiani
Jillian Bell and a bunch of other people
that's the amazing cast in a super-fun
show funny guy and so when you're
putting this together producing it or
directing it or writing it I mean how
much like how do you guys collaborate
how do you guys work together I mean the
closest I'll work out yeah the best part
of this job is you know collaborating
with other artists and and batting ideas
around and and in this case it was
mostly about trying to support Emily and
the thing that she wanted to do and
pitch her jokes and sit there in the
recording booth and like when we were
staff writers hope that she tries our
bit and and to try to give her any
whatever wisdom we have it really more
than anything it was just enjoying
everybody's awesome work and then coming
here and taking credit for and I've done
Phil yeah
yeah we're some of the best in the biz
what's it what is the one franchise or
pop culture product that you'd love to
take a crack at and put your own spin on
it if you could give it I mean obviously
you've taken you've been able to take
you know all of the hot properties like
21 Jump Street and Cloudy with a Chance
of me so exactly like what I would
normally think that you'd want to take a
swing it one of those so it's always
like something we find in the couch
cushions yeah no one else is using and
we're getting more into doing some
original stuff these days because we've
done a lot of like taking these like
hidden hidden gems but I think you know
sometimes we stuff is cool too we want
to create something for future
generations to reboot okay executives of
the future what are they yeah what are
they gonna what bad ideas are they gonna
come up with if you could give the
Dolphins an idea Phil I'm telling you
trust the process it's gonna be fine
it's a long con it's a long 25 years
it's a you guys have a lot of draft
picks yeah you've got you've got some
hope I know you can get to a like
tomorrow if you wanted but the Bengals
are lurking sucking just as much I know
they lurk and I feel like this I just
feel like this team is just trying to
win games well Ryan Fitzpatrick as you
know no Ryan no I don't know does he's
the last he's the worst getting the memo
guy he's never done he's try to win game
he's an Ivy Leaguer like you guys I know
well we we weird you know
Dartmouth guys and we were big Jay
Fiedler fans we were there and he was
and he he had like look I've come from
behind victories in this last Dartmouth
season and one of them was quick they
were downforce touchdowns and going in
the fourth quarter yeah in the snow say
one what did what a Jay Fiedler big man
on campus on Dartmouth looked like did
he stroll around like the [ __ ] of the
walk
I mean and Chris you're gonna be fired
up the Seahawks er they see XR squeaking
by every week and and I am here for it
I mean he's amazing VP I would agree
CIL's MV how come you did not get him in
your fantasy team we did Russell Wilson
and we've got the New England defense
and those two players alone are keeping
us afloat in the in this year they are
the pillars of our temple well thank you
for community thank you for coming on
guys really bless the hearts has been
picked up for another season renewed for
season number two check it out on Fox at
8:30 p.m. Eastern Time every single
night if you guys wouldn't mind just
sitting here Phil Lord and Chris Miller
Chris Brockman I've never opened
residual checks we had a guest sitting
to my right who perhaps have put a
residual check okay you know I did 22
Jump Street that's right that's why
you're the film was as successful as it
was you put me in though that's why
you're gonna get that 14 cents for
residuals could you imagine with Phil
Lord and Chris Miller here and it is in
fact for 22 Jump Street it's entirely
possible let's go the only thing they
could come crows could come even in that
neighborhood is we have David Caruso on
as a guest and I opened a CSI Miami
check that's the only thing that comes
close to that good to see you guys being
come back I will do that and when we
return for the radio audience Chris
Brockman sneaky good games hopefully
will go as well as his pick for Thursday
Night Football us
that's next on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app